[Música]
preocupación de la organización
panamericana de la salud respecto al
comportamiento de la pandemia en américa
lado pelé la ope se calificó de
alarmante el aumento exponencial de las
infecciones sobre todo en américa del
sur sin embargo afirmó que no es
sorprendente debido a la relajación de
las medidas de confinamiento
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
anunció la retirada de todas las tropas
estadounidenses de afganistán antes del
vigésimo aniversario de los atentados
del 11 de septiembre de 2001
bailén defendió la decisión afirmando
que eeuu cumplió su objetivo al
desmantelar al qaeda y mataron su
entonces líder osama bin laden los
aliados de la otan seguirán los pasos de
eeuu
el organismo internacional para la
energía atómica aseguró que irán está
casi listo para comenzar a enriquecer
uranio por encima del 60%
el presidente del país persa hassan
rohan y asegura que dicho
enriquecimiento se es en respuesta al
ataque contra la planta de natanz a del
que señala israel como responsable el
secretario de estado estadounidense
calificó la decisión de provocadora y de
cara a una nueva ronda de diálogos en
viena
muy buena noche gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france24 blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en américa que según la organización
panamericana de la salud no se está
comportando como una región que
experimenta un brote cada vez más grave
de kobe 19 según la directora de este
organismo el aumento de las infecciones
es alarmante pero no sorprendente en
medio de la relajación de las medidas de
confinamiento y añadió que la vacunación
no será suficiente para detener esta ola
de contagios en los últimos siete días
se han infectado más personas de kobe 19
en la región que durante la mayoría de
las semanas del año pasado mientras que
las muertes semanales superan a las de
cualquier semana de 2020
y más personas se han contagiado con
kobe 19 en nuestra región en los últimos
7 días más que la mayoría de los
promedios semanales de casos que vimos
el año pasado
halloween nuestras muertes semanales
superan en número a las de cualquier
semana en 2020
el rebrote de coke 19 en brasil y la
agresividad de la variante amazónica del
virus está afectando cada vez más a las
personas más jóvenes según los datos
hospitalarios en el último mes más del
52% de los pacientes en estado grave
ingresados en las uci eran menores de 40
años y según un informe independiente
esta población tiende a pasar más tiempo
en cuidados intensivos brasil epicentro
de la pandemia mundial acumula más de
358 mil fallecimientos marina sardenya
nos amplía la información
por primera vez desde el inicio de la
pandemia los jóvenes brasileños son los
más afectados por el cob y 19 desde
marzo más del 52% de las camas de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos están
ocupadas por pacientes de 40 años o
menos según el informe de la asociación
brasileña de medicina intensiva un
significativo aumento en comparación con
la ocupación de este rango de edad entre
diciembre y febrero del 16 5% de
secuencia mantenida esta enfermedad no
tiene edad es muy triste
desgraciadamente de un día para otro te
puede llevar muy muy triste el reporte
se basa en datos del 25 por ciento de
las uci de brazil el epicentro mundial
de la pandemia según los expertos esta
tendencia de la pandemia sugiere que la
variante brasileña del virus es más
agresiva con la población joven las que
la vacunación de los adultos mayores ha
ayudado a contener los casos graves
entre los ancianos
en la primera ola vimos principalmente a
personas mayores pero esto no es lo que
estamos viendo ahora es una enfermedad
que se ha mostrado más agresiva sobre
todo en los más jóvenes ya que estos
jóvenes aplazan la visita al hospital
la nación suramericana está sumida en
una nueva crisis de la enfermedad con
más de 4 mil decesos diarios la semana
pasada un rebrote que se refleja en su
desbordado sistema de salud una de cada
cuatro ciudades brasileñas tiene lista
de espera de pacientes en estado grave
que aguardan por una cama de las ucis
nosotros hemos sido testigos de un gran
número de pacientes que han fallecido
debido a la falta de camas de la uci en
el estado de sao paulo estado de la
gestión de la pandemia hembras y él ha
estado marcada por el negacionismo del
gobierno de jair bolsonaro el incremento
de jóvenes preocupa a las autoridades
sanitarias en un país donde la mayor
parte de su población es menor de 40
años
vamos hasta brasilia donde se encuentra
nuestro invitado michael lópez el
cientista político y socio de la empresa
arko advice gracias por estar con
nosotros señor lópez ante la preocupante
situación de la pandemia en brasil la
corte suprema de ese país confirmó una
decisión anterior de uno de sus jueces
de que el senado instale un comité para
investigar la respuesta del gobierno
federal a la pandemia de coronavirus
donde se ve directamente implicado el
presidente ya ir bolsonaro qué pasará
con esta investigación y cómo afectaría
al presidente le pregunta además si hay
posibilidad de un impeachment
saludos un placer hablar contigo ahora
sí esa esa fue la decisión más
importante de hoy el supremo tribunal
federal
básicamente forzó el senado a instalar
esta comisión de investigación
parlamentaria
y ese era un requerimiento que ya estaba
en el senado desde febrero de este año
entonces la presión política por
respuestas o una fiscalización de las
acciones del gobierno federal está
existente desde el año pasado en brasil
con esta decisión el juez determinó que
el senado y me sigue la comete la
comisión para hacer estas
investigaciones
ahora el senado ya indicó los miembros
de este comité ellos van a investigar
las acciones del gobierno pudiendo traer
ministros de estado para hablar con los
miembros del senado con los miembros de
la comisión y apurar en las acciones del
gobierno federal
sobre el impeachment claro que la
oposición
contra el bolsón aro ese es el gol no
ese es el intento pero es necesario
entender que el gobierno bolsonaro fue
capaz de construir una base en el
congreso especialmente en enero durante
las elecciones del presidente de la
cámara y del senado entonces eso con su
popularidad que está más o menos a 50
por ciento dificulta un y pico ahora
maicon la comisión también podrá
investigar posibles irregularidades en
estados y municipios brasileños con esto
también se podrían ver perjudicados
gobernadores y alcaldes que han sido
duramente criticados por el presidente o
visionario
pues sí esa es una cuestión esa fue la
principal pregunta jurídica sobre esta
conducción la estrategia del gobierno
era que las investigaciones estuviera
enfocadas en los estados y en los
gobernadores el presidente del senado
senador rodrigo pacheco e inició un
requerimiento técnico sobre la
posibilidad de incluir estados y
municipios en las investigaciones del
comité pero existen límites
constitucionales de lo que el senado
federal puede investigar entonces
en un principio el comité oa enfocar en
lo federal tener claro
los repasos a los estados también van a
ser investigados
maikel gracias por su tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 nosotros
continuamos con más información en
estados unidos el presidente joe biden
dijo este miércoles que planea poner fin
a la guerra más larga del país y que es
hora de que las tropas estadounidenses
regresen a casa desde afganistán el
retiro comenzará de manera paulatina a
partir del primero de mayo y la fecha
límite será el 11 de septiembre cuando
estado
a 20 años de los ataques terroristas del
11 de septiembre de ese año 2001 y la
salida será en coordinación con la otan
que también sacará a sus soldados del
terreno
para sesionar que creo que nuestra
presencia en afganistán debería estar
centrada en la razón por la que fuimos
en primer lugar para asegurarnos que
afganistán no sea usado como base para
atacar a nuestra patria nosotros
cumplimos con ese objetivo no nos
apresuraremos a salir corriendo lo
haremos de manera responsable y segura y
con total coordinación con nuestros
aliados y socios que ahora tienen más
fuerzas en afganistán que nosotros
cuestionar quienes tienen windows luego
del anuncio del presidente de eeuu joe
biden de retirar sus tropas de
afganistán la otan confirmó que
comenzará el repliegue de sus efectivos
a partir del 1º de mayo esther herrera
nuestra corresponsal en bruselas con los
detalles
la otan seguirá a estados unidos y
también retirará sus tropas de
afganistán a partir del 1 de mayo y
terminará antes del 11 de septiembre así
lo ha anunciado el secretario general de
la organización james stoltenberg
después de una reunión con los ministros
de defensa y de exteriores de la alianza
en una reunión en la que estaba también
presente el secretario de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken y también el de defensa
y hoy
austin ambos de viaje oficial en
bruselas la otan considera que es
momento de seguir adelante que las
soluciones que requiere actualmente
afganistán no son militares por el
momento la otan tiene desplegadas 10.000
tropas por todo el país y es que a pesar
de las amenazas de los talibanes la otan
ha asegurado que si hay atentados contra
sus tropas actuará en consecuencia a
pesar de todo el mundo ha cambiado por
completo en estos últimos 20 años según
ha señalado
anthony blinken y sobre todo es momento
de que la alianza mire hacia el futuro y
también hacia otros retos como por
ejemplo la
creciente tensión o por parte de rusia
según ha recordado la otan ya es momento
de seguir adelante porque tal y como ha
recordado el secretario general de la
otan james stoltenberg se marchó hacia
afganistán junto a eeuu y es momento de
abandonar también el país centroasiático
junto a eeuu en otras noticias el
organismo internacional para la energía
atómica asegura que eran está casi listo
para iniciar la producción de uranio
enriquecido al 60% veamos
es una de las grandes batallas
geopolíticas del año y los protagonistas
toman parte el presidente iraní hassan
rohan y anunció el aumento del
enriquecimiento de uranio tras el
sabotaje en su planta de natanz del que
acusan a israel
nuestra respuesta a su malicia de
reemplazar las centrifugadoras y r1 por
las y r6 y aumentar el enriquecimiento
60% en las instalaciones de natanz por
el actual de 3 67 %
desde irán aseguran que la planta ha
recibido grandes daños tras el ataque
afectando a miles de centrifugadoras y
r1 por eso las van a sustituir por
nuevas de alta generación que
acelerarían el enriquecimiento y les
acercaría al 90 por ciento necesario
para fabricar armas nucleares sin
embargo el acuerdo de 2015 de viena
establecía una limitación del 3 67 por
ciento mientras el organismo
internacional de la energía atómica tras
visitar las instalaciones de natanz
aseguró que irán está haciendo todo para
empezar a enriquecer más un año de hecho
la agencia fue notificada de que el país
persa va a activar 1024 centrifugadoras
uno más superando el límite de 5000 que
establecía el pacto de viana desde eeuu
anthony blinken secretario de estado
mostró preocupación nos tomamos muy en
serio su provocadora anuncio sobre su
intención de comenzar a enriquecer
uranio al 60%
del otro lado irán cuenta con el apoyo
de rusia tras la visita del canciller a
teherán y de china que criticó
públicamente el ataque a natanz singer
los asaltos a las instalaciones
nucleares son de naturaleza muy grave y
pueden causar consecuencias
impredecibles
china se opone defendemos los acuerdos
políticos sobre el problema nuclear de
estas tensiones suceden justo antes de
una nueva reunión para tratar de revivir
el acuerdo nuclear de 2015
eeuu aboga por un retorno al
cumplimiento de lo pactado mientras que
teherán exige un levantamiento total de
las sanciones en su contra
níger está de luto luego de que 20
menores de edad de entre 3 y 5 años
quedaran atrapados en las llamas de un
incendio en una escuela a las afueras de
la ciudad tenía may la capital del país
todos murieron ya que las instalaciones
se fueron rápidamente consumidas por el
fuego
estas son las instalaciones donde
estaban los niños fallecidos en un
incendio que tiene a níger de luto al
menos 20 menores de edad quedaron
atrapados en las llamas que devoraron
una escuela en el barrio de pib en la
ciudad de niamey horas después de la
tragedia el primer ministro visitó el
lugar y dijo que habría un castigo si se
comprueba que alguien inició el incendio
deliberadamente el criminal
si el incendio se trata de un crimen
entonces tengan la seguridad de que
encontraremos a los perpetradores y
haremos todo lo posible para asegurarnos
de que reciban una sentencia máxima
porque no es aceptable perder niños tan
pequeños es realmente triste expreso mi
más sentido pésame a las familias todas
mis condolencias la escuela incendiada
tiene cerca de 800 estudiantes incluidos
niños en guardería fueron los más
pequeños las víctimas de esta tragedia
de preescolar sur kim se trata
principalmente en niños en edad
preescolar de 3 4 y 5 años también hay
niños más grandes pero no son muchos tal
vez hay dos o tres de ellos
pero la mayoría de los que murieron
quemados en esta tragedia son los del
preescolar porque son los más pequeños y
no pudieron correr el round los equipos
de rescate trabajaron rápidamente pero
no lograron controlar la intensidad del
fuego el viento hizo que las llamas
llegaran a varios salones de clase las
autoridades aún no conocen el origen del
incendio en níger que está entre los 10
países más pobres del mundo según el
índice de desarrollo humano de la onu
este tipo de aulas al aire libre se
utilizan a menudo para dar cabida a los
estudiantes en escuelas superpobladas
hasta que el informativo continua con
nosotros
[Música]